is doug bradley the sexiest cenobite on
the mortal plane you decide for yourself
once you see what pinhead looks like in
real life although clive barker didn't
name the lead cenobite pinhead and his
novella the hell-bound heart the
character's distinctive appearance
earned the nickname that stuck
throughout the hellraiser series since
the movie's release in 1987 english
actor doug bradley has become synonymous
with a soul-harvesting pinhead bradley
is part of a special group of horror
actors who have played their haunting
characters at least six times in a row a
list that includes tobin bell as jigsaw
warwick davis as leprechaun brad dorf as
chucky christopher lee as dracula and
robert england as freddy krueger bradley
opted not to return for 2011's
hellraiser revelations and the saga
seems to have moved on without him
2018's hellraiser judgment marked the
second installment to feature a
different actor under the makeup still
he'll always be pinhead to us and we
have to think the majority of the
franchise fans agree